evaluate three and a half minus X when X
is equal to five and X is equal to
negative five and there's a bunch of
different ways to think about this and
we'll just go through all of them in
this video so first of all we just can
evaluate this expression when first when
X is equal to 5 so it evaluates as 3 and
1/2 minus instead of an X we have a 5
over there and so let's draw this on the
number line let's draw a number line
over here and I'll see this is 0 1 2 3 &
4 let me put some negative numbers here
negative 1 negative 2 as well and we're
starting at 3 & a half we are starting
at 3 and a half and so there's a couple
of ways you can visualize what it means
to subtract 5 from 3 and a half since
we're subtracting a positive number you
could view that literally is just
stepping five to the left so let's do
that so minus five literally means
stepping five to the left so one two
three four five and it gets us to
negative one and a half and that would
be the right answer negative one and a
half another way to think about it and
it would really involve the same idea of
stepping five for the left but thinking
about it from a slightly different angle
is that three and a half minus five you
could rewrite it as three and a half
subtracting anything is the same thing
as adding the opposite of that number so
it would be the same thing as adding it
would be the same thing as adding
negative five and this might be a little
bit more useful for you because you
could actually visualize what the what
each of these numbers look like at the
number line and then you could think
about what it means to add them let me
show you give you an example of that if
I have if I have the number one if I
wanted to draw it on a number line it
looks like this this is 0 this is 1 this
is 2 and we could keep going and we
could also go in the negative direction
but one actually let me do it in pink
one would look like this one would look
like this if I were to do one plus two
so if I were to do one plus two well
let's independently draw what to looks
like on the number line so let me draw
two over here so if I have two two on
the number line
two on the number line we could have 0 1
2 3 2 on the number line and this is you
know you learn this when you were very
young but I'm just gonna make you maybe
you look at it in a slightly different
way to on a number line looks like this
so what is 1 plus 2 so let's draw our
number line let's draw another number
line over here let's draw another number
9 0 1 2 3 & 4 so if you have 1 plus 2
1+2 you're gonna start at 1 so you have
the number 1 there just like we drew it
over there and when you add 2 to it when
you add 2 to it you start off where you
left off with the 1 and then you add 2
from that point and this is all you know
this is all hopefully reviewed for you
and then you get to 3 you get to the
number 3 or if you add up those two
arrows you get to the number 3 this is
equal to 3 so the same idea is when
we're doing when we're adding a negative
number so let's do it that way so we can
already think about what 3 and 1/2 looks
like 3 and a half I'll draw it over here
3 and 1/2 looks like this if we draw it
with an arrow 3 and 1/2 would look like
that that would be 3 and 1/2 what does
negative 5 look like I'll draw another
number line here to draw negative 5 so
let me draw so if we have negative 6
negative 5 negative 4 negative 3
negative 2 negative 1 0 1 2 negative 5
looks like this it is it has an absolute
value of 5 and it has a length or it has
a it is 5 away from 0 but it's to the
left of 0 so negative 5 looks like this
negative 5 looks like this so if we're
going to take 3 and we're going to add
negative 5 you do the exact same thing
wherever we left off or we're going to
take 3 and a half and add negative 5
wherever we left off with 3 and a half
we then place and that we then add
negative 5 to it so we start over here
and we add negative 5 we add this number
so we put our arrow we could put it
right over there but it'd make it hard
to read we take our arrows
aren't there and then we put negative we
add negative five to it and adding
negative five is completely equivalent
to going five spaces to the left on the
number line so whatever is a more
helpful way of visualizing it that's
fine as long as you really understand
what it means to subtract five or what
it means to subtract a larger number
from a smaller number and really
understand why it got us to negative one
and a half now let's try the same thing
when X is equal to negative five x is
equal to negative five so this
expression will become this expression
will become three and a half - instead
of an X we're not going to have a
negative 5 3 & a half minus negative
five and once again several ways to
think about this but maybe the easier
one and this one is to think of
subtraction as we said before
subtracting a number is the same thing
as adding its opposite so in this case
subtracting a number is the same thing
this is the same thing as adding its
opposite so subtracting negative five is
the same thing as adding as adding
positive five or this is just the same
thing as adding five so you could just
say this is same thing as three and a
half plus five another way to think
about it is that and you'll hear this in
some context is that when you have two
negatives if you subtract a negative
that cancels out subtracting a negative
is the same thing as adding a positive
they're really just two different ways
of saying the same thing but three and a
half plus five you might be able to do
in your head three and a half is three
plus one half and then to that we're
going to add five three plus five is
eight plus one half is eight and a half
or if we want to do it the way we've
been doing everything else we could draw
it out on the number line so I'll start
at zero let me draw the number line zero
one two three four five six seven eight
nine and so we're starting at three and
a half so this is three and a half right
let me do this in another color so we're
going to start at three and a half this
is three and a half and to that we are
going to add five we're going to add
five I could
independently plot five on the number
line when we're adding five so we're
actually going to shift it and we're
going to start it with three and a half
left off and we're going to add five so
the length right over here is five and
we're in five to the right we're adding
a positive number five to the right gets
us to eight and a half we've moved five
spaces one two three four five so
hopefully that makes some sense to you
and it was a little bit long-winded but
the reason why I wanted to go
long-winded was so that no matter how
it's explained to you you understand
that the basic idea is the same